so a lot of people claim that
professional wrestling is fake well how
fake is it we thought we would talk to
an actual professional wrestler in fact
one of the most famous Hacksaw Jim
Duggan and he respectfully respectfully
disagrees we talked to him for a brand
new episode of Tucker Carlson today
here's part of it
[Music]
back then do you think it's fake you
come up in a ring with you and we'll
show you it's fake or not so he had to
fight every local tough guy there is you
know and of course that's the old joke
you're always a phony wrestler
well until you go to court
you go to court you're just trained
Killer goes like that 10 20 30 000.
every time you hit him that lawsuit goes
up you know they're like I'm going to
sue you I said I'm getting my money's
worth we're not done brother
so what were the guys so this was even
though it was in the 70s it wasn't in
the 20s but was really a different time
right much different business it was a
really rough tough Carnival type
business yeah back then people were Marx
you try to work them out of their money
not with sports entertainment
International what does that mean they
were marks you try working out well yeah
like a carnival type term you know
people you're trying to work them out of
their money get them to give their money
somehow trying to work them out of their
money that's was never my idea I said I
put on a performance those folks pay to
come watch me perform were you on the
road and I was on the road yeah an awful
lot that's one of the hard things about
wrestling is the road you know
especially back then in the old WWF
which was the Golden Age of wrestling
Hulk Hogan Jake
Macho Man Andre the Giant yeah you would
work all the time because you didn't
have contracts if you didn't work you
didn't get paid if you got hurt you
didn't have a contract no no no he if
you wrestled you got paid so if you were
on top like I was working with Andre the
Giant I knocked Andre out with my 2x4 we
were on top I worked with him 54 nights
straight
later in that same interview hacksaw
told us about how a home invader
unfortunately for him showed up at his
home and he detained the man using his
44. you can watch the whole interview
with Hacksaw Jim Duggan now on Fox
Nation
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight